قطار سام يغضب سكان ولايه اوهايو
الامريكيه بعد اسبوعين على حادثه القطار
الذي خرج عن مساره وادى الى انفجار ضخم
نتج عنه سحابه غاز ضخمه حملت مواد
كيميائيه
وسامه ومصرطنه وفقا للسلطات المحليه هناك
سكان المنطقه طالبوا السلطات بضمانات بشان
صحتهم المهدده مع استمرار انبعاث الروائح
السامه بعد اسبوعين من الحادث الانفجار
كان وقع في بلده تدعى شرق فلسطين يسكنها
حوالي خمسه الاف شخص وعندما خرج القطار عن
مساره كان يحمل ماده كلوريد فاينل التي
تسببت وتسبب مرض السرطان شركه سكك الحديد
المشغله اوضحت ان 20 عربه من بين اكثر من
100 عربه في القطار كانت تحمل مواد خطره
والقطار كذب متجها من ماده
فينيا سبب انحراف القطار عن مساره وفق
التحقيقات الاوليه تقول انه ربما بسبب
مشكله ميكانيكيه في محور عربه السكك
الحديديه وراي اخر اعتبر ان ربما كانت
الحموله الزائده هي السبب ماده الكلوريد
الفاينل الكلوريد التي انفجرت وتحولت الى
غازات سامه تستخدم بصناعه البلاستيك الصلب
كما هو معروف لاجل ذلك تحركت وكاله حمايه
البيئه لمراقبه جوده الهواء كل يوم حتى
الاطمئنان من نقاء الهواء من اي مواد سامه